yeah not just to be nominated but front
runner to win really so yeah very a big
deal for her but then you know there's
all kinds of challenges coming up in
those supporting nomination categories
it's a bit less clear than in previous
years I think some of those so those are
some of the big big films that the you
know internationally people will have
heard of but also uh some of the smaller
ones uh and and well not that's more
suppose the Banshees of an assurance and
a lot of Irish talent potentially going
to be nominated this year it is shaping
up to be an incredible year for for
Irish acting Talent yeah if anything
more than the the Brits that we're
talking about this yeah certainly
banshees of industry and it looks like
it's going to put Colin Farrell in uh
Colin Farrell in uh contention for best
actor also of course Brendan Gleason is
likely to be for best supporting
um yeah just it's just an incredible
Talent within that possibly up against
his own co-star in supporting Barry
Keegan it looks like they could both be
in that sort of category against each
other and then a lot of people are
saying will Paul meskel sneak into best
Act acting for after sun it's a fairly
small independent movie but he's of
course known for normal people yeah very
famous wearing of a necklace exactly
yeah the chains did the necklace
I mean it's the Oscars they always
surprise us you never know and who are
the other men that potentially could do
well Brendan Fraser they're saying it
might be a sort of two-horse race
Brendan Fraser for the whale going up
against Colin Farrell um Brendan Fraser
you spoke to him actually didn't you
it's an incredible performance the
Prosthetics that he he has for playing
with a beast man yeah hugely obese man
and and um the film's not out in the UK
yet so it's one to kind of start getting
excited about with that nomination but
he's had such an interesting kind of
narrative he sort of has had something
of a comeback uh story with this film
and it's a huge performance from him a
brilliant performance from him I'm not
sure the film will necessarily get heaps
of other nominations but he's set to be
a front-runner in the actor category
definitely and what about the women
we've talked about some of the men who
might be up for best mattress again
they're saying that the Two Front
Runners this year are likely to be uh
Kate Blanchett for tar playing this
um slightly toxic uh very woman in a
position of power as a conductor uh with
the Berlin Philharmonic it's an
incredible performance for her she had
to learn to play the piano she had to
learn to conduct an orchestra she had to
learn German
um so certainly she's put the effort in
she would deserve on that front to win
up against Michelle Geo as the the other
main name that's being mentioned really
for everything everywhere all at once
who plays this laundrette owner who ends
up jumping between the Multiverse and
having to save the universe but Andrea
risborough can we just very quickly talk
about talk about Andrew so all well a
lot of the actresses within Hollywood
have been making real efforts to point
out the fact that Andrea risborough
hasn't got much attention for the film
to Leslie and that she really deserves
to for her performance yeah it's an
incredible there's two Leslie out in the
UK I've not heard of it no it's not and
to be honest it's been barely been out
anywhere has taken hardly any money at
Premiere a um a film festival that isn't
one that's known for kind of starting
off Oscar campaign so it's sort of come
out of nowhere we think it's a really
really well managed campaign that
perhaps they didn't have loads of money
to run the usual marketing and PR
strategy that is what tends to happen in
Hollywood when someone's trying to go
for an Oscar Nom and instead it was a
very short sharp week of lots of people
talking about this movie and getting
names like Kate Winslet Jennifer
Alliston talking about this movie
uh so we've only got a few seconds to go
until it starts who's hosting it who's
who's announcing these awards today oh I
don't think there's anyone particularly
yeah
we're waiting for it to pop up I think
we can go to it now let's cross it to
the academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences Janet yang
good morning everyone and welcome to the
Oscars nominations announcement it is so
exciting to be back live once again to
kick off the official countdown to the
95th Oscars on March 12th for nearly a
century now
the Oscars has been the most esteemed
celebration of movies in the world it is
a chance for us to showcase the very
best films of the past year and for
Global movie fans to come together as we
shine a spotlight on artists working on
both sides of the camera
every year a nominees in most categories
are chosen by their peers actors
nominate actors film editors vote for
the best edited movies of the year and
so on but the final and most anticipated
Award Best Picture is chosen by the
entire Academy membership that's around
10 000 filmmakers and artists living and
working in over 80 countries and now to
present the nominees here are today's
hosts
2022 Oscar winner Riz Ahmed and the star
and executive producer of Megan Allison
Williams
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody we've been awake all night
getting ready for this moment
and we're so excited so honored so over
caffeinated to reveal the nominations
for the 95th Oscars good morning
everybody Riz I am so happy to be here
with you you've been nominated twice and
you won an Oscar last year so I just
wanted to know did you watch this both
of those times
um I did watch it yeah but I didn't wake
up to watch it and the reason for that
is I never really fell asleep in the
first place there was just a lot of
anticipation and I know there's a lot of
people who can't wait for us to get
started so without further Ado here are
the nominees for performance by an
actress in a supporting role
Angela Bassett in Black Panther wakanda
forever
Hong Chao in the whale
Kerry Condon in the Banshees of inner
sharing
Jamie Lee Curtis in everything
everywhere all at once
and Stephanie shu
in everything everywhere all at once
next are the nominees for achievement in
costume design
Babylon
black panther wakanda forever
Elvis
everything everywhere all at once
and Mrs Harris goes to Paris
where is given the extraordinary sound
design on your film sound of metal why
don't you take this next category well
here are the nominees for achievement in
sound
All Quiet on the Western Front
Avatar the way of water
the Batman
Elvis
and top gun Maverick
next up here are the nominees for
achievement in music original score
All Quiet on the Western Front
Babylon yes
the Banshees of Ina Sharon
everything everywhere all at once
and the fablemens
[Applause]
and now we have the first of the two
award categories that honor writers the
first is adapted screenplay
the nominees are
All Quiet on the Western Front
screenplay by Edward Berger Leslie
Patterson and Ian stokel
Glass Onion a Knives Out mystery written
by Ryan Johnston
living written by kazuo ishiguro
and top gun Maverick screenplay by Aaron
Kruger and Eric horn singer and
Christopher macquarie's Story by Peter
Craig and Justin marks
and women talking
screenplay by Sarah Polly
and here are the nominees for original
screenplay
the Banshees avinasharon written by
Martin McDonough
everything everywhere all at once
written by Daniel Kwan and Daniel
scheinert
the fablemans written by Steven
Spielberg and Tony Kushner
tar written by Todd field
and triangle of sadness written by
Reuben Usman
now it's with great pleasure that I get
to announce this year's nominees for
best live-action short film
an Irish goodbye
ifalu
Le pupila
night ride
and the red suitcase
are now the nominees for best animated
short film
the boy the mole The Fox and the horse
the flying sailor
these merchants
my year of dicks
[Applause]
and and ostrich told me the world is
fake and I think I believe it
ah
no comment here are the nominees for
performance by an actor in a supporting
role
Brendan Gleason in the Banshees of Anna
Sharon
Brian Tyree Henry in Causeway
Judd Hirsch in the fablemans
Barry Keogan in the Banshees of in a
Sharon
and Ki Hui Kwan in everything everywhere
all at all
rizz this is a delight I don't want this
to end I have to say it's much easier
working with you than Megan she is
tricky yeah
she's not around is she
uh you promised me that she wouldn't be
around yeah
no we should be good we're good okay
cool uh anyway we'll be right back
because in just a few minutes we've got
more nominee announcements coming up
so that is the first branch of those
Oscar nominations uh let's bring in our
top entertainment team here
um so the big ones really are in that
there were the lots of the smaller ones
but the supporting actor and supporting
actress and also original screen paint
adapted screenplay
fairly how we expected to in terms of
the Irish um acting Talent that's
nominated best supporting actor you've
got Brendan Gleason for Banshees of
inner sharing you've got Barry Keegan as
well for the same film
um Brian Tyree Henry perhaps a bit of a
shot I think that was a bit of a
surprise for Causeway lots of people had
rated that performance but it had been
fairly quiet that film perhaps wasn't
one that people were talking about so
much so um really great to see him in
there that the fact is I guess a good
performance does break through no matter
if the chatter isn't there best
supporting actress as we said Angela so
that is a big big one yeah those in the
Marvel offices will be popping champagne
at this very minute and like I said
she's already sort of in the front
runner to win the category having
already won of the Globes and the
Critics Choice so
um yeah really exciting moment for them
and again you've got these pairs so two
actresses from everything everywhere all
at once Jamie Lee Curtis and Stephanie
shoes so uh it's interesting to see that
they'll be sort of slugging it out
against one another to try and come
through you're in charge of the tally am
I right in thinking that everything
everywhere all at once is leading them
yeah at this point that's the one that's
got the most nominations closely
followed by banshees I mean it is only
halfway through so but it's a it's a
good strong start for both of those
films which we had expected to do well
and then yeah with all the others that
we expected to pop up have been
including
um women talking and Glass Onion which
maybe hadn't they didn't get any at the
baftas so it shows that there really is
a divide between what the British
Academy and the American Academy are
interested in but speaking of the baftas
as well last week we were talking about
the 12 nominations for All Quiet on the
Western Front this German language film
about the first world war again that is
a name that's popping up certainly it
was they've got nominated in writing
yeah music and adapted screenplay yeah
for that it's likely that they'll come
up again for um makeup I would have
thought as well sort of the top top gun
got a couple of nominations there and in
technical categical dwell in adapted
screenplay and in sound and they'll be
pleased with that won't they absolutely
yeah I mean I think everyone was just
thought it was going to be a summer
blockbuster smash this is sort of the
validation that you seek from your peers
that everyone was just sort of Blown
Away with the the production values that
went into that film so it'd be
interesting to see what else yeah and
those screenplay categories often really
good kind of hints at what we will see
in best picture so I think you know
that's getting exciting by surprise yeah
we're almost uh yeah we're almost kind
of certain I'm not sure should I say
that to see Top Gun in that in that 10
that best 10 list now
um it's yeah it's shaping up to be a
really interesting race actually
um and then towards the end there the
short film and the animated short film
lots of Snickers at some of the titles
in the animated short film
um oh we're going back they're sparing
our blushes we're going back the
nominees for the 95th Oscars now earlier
we announced nine categories coming up
now at the Final 14 including best
picture
here are the nominees for achievement in
music original song
Applause from Tell It Like a Woman
hold my hand from Top Gun Maverick
lift me up from Black Panther wakanda
forever
not to not to from RR
and this is a life from everything
everywhere all at once
foreign
next up the nominees for best
documentary feature film
all that breathes
all the Beauty and the bloodship
fire of love
a house made of splinters
and navalny
and here are the nominees for best
documentary short film
the elephant Whisperers
haul out
how do you measure a year
the Martha Mitchell effect
and stranger at the gate
hear the nominees for best International
feature film
All Quiet on the Western Front Germany
Argentina in 1985 Argentina
close Belgium
EO Poland
and the quiet girl Ireland
here are the nominees for best animated
feature film
Guillermo del toroz Pinocchio
Marcel the Shell with Shoes On
Puss in Boots the last one
the Sea Beast
and turning red
here are the nominees for achievement in
makeup and hair styling
All Quiet on the Western Front
the Batman
black panther wakanda forever
Elvis
and the whale
[Applause]
here are the nominees for achievement in
production design
All Quiet on the Western Front
Avatar the way of water
Babylon
Elvis
and the fableds
the nominees for achievement in film
editing are
the Banshees of in a Sharon
everything everywhere all at once
tar
and top gun Maverick
next up the nominees for achievement in
cinematography
all quiets on the Western Front
of false Chronicle and a handful of
troops
Elvis
Empire of light
and tar
foreign
and now achievement in visual effects
All Quiet on the Western Front
Avatar the way of water
the Batman
black panther wakanda forever
and top gun Maverick
it's time for our final four Awards
here are the nominees for performance by
an actor in a leading role
Austin Butler and Elvis
Colin Farrell in the Banshees of in
Ashera
Brendan Fraser in the whale
Paul meskel and after sun
and Bill Nye in living
thank you
and now the five nominees for
performance by an actress in a leading
role
Kate Blanchett in tar
Anna De armas
Andrea reisborough into Leslie
Michelle Williams in the fablemans
and Michelle yo in everything everywhere
thank you
just two categories Remain the first is
achievement in directing and the
nominees are
Martin McDonough the Banshees of inner
Sharon
Daniel Kwan and Daniel sheinert
everything everywhere all at once
Steven Spielberg the fablemans
Todd field tar
and Reuben usland triangle of sadness
now the final category here are the ten
nominees for best motion picture of the
year
Quiet on the Western Front mounted Blue
Notes producer
Avatar the way of water James Cameron
and John Landau producers
the Banshees of inner Sharon Graham
Broadbent Pete Charmin and Martin
McDonough producers
Elvis baslerman Catherine Martin Gail
Berman Patrick McCormick and Skyler
Weiss producers
everything everywhere all at once Daniel
Kwan Daniel sheinert and Jonathan Wong
producers
[Applause]
the fablemans Christy mccosko Krieger
Steven Spielberg and Tony Kushner
producers
tar Todd field Alexander milshon and
Scott Lambert producers
top gun Maverick Tom Cruise Christopher
Macquarie David Ellison and Jerry
Bruckheimer producers
triangle of sadness Eric hemendorf and
philippec producers
and women talking
Deedee Gardner Jeremy Kleiner and
Francis McDormand producers
[Applause]
this was such an honor and huge
congratulations to all the nominees
I hope you really soak up this moment
and enjoy everything that lies ahead and
in case you didn't know Saturday
February 11th is global movie day so go
see the nominated movies at your local
theater tell them we sent you and be
better prepared for your Oscar pool and
thank you for joining us and be sure to
watch the 95th Oscars live with host
Jimmy Kimmel Sunday March 12th
well there we have it let's return to
Kate Spencer
excitement any massive surprises a
really a really good surprise Paul
mascal has to be surely I was going to
say Andrea rise for us yeah nobody's
been pushing us well I'll say the Brits
but I you know I don't want to you know
not include the Irish in this as well
but essentially people from this side of
the ponds have done really well in the
in in the actor and actress categories
yeah Andrea risper though it's such a
coup that she's pulled off having this
nomination because it's a tiny tiny
small budget film hasn't had a
distributor to Leslie it's called her
her playing a woman who won the lottery
then lost all her money in them has
become struggling with addictions
um but it's just been pushed by all of
the other actresses who have highlighted
it and said look you can't have an award
season without this woman being
mentioned in contention and Brilliant
now we've got a British actress that we
can all talk about in the run-up and
there were a lot there are lots of films
there that we expect said when we look
at the best Motion Picture category All
Quiet on the Western Front Avatar the
boundaries of miniature and Elvis
everything everywhere all at once Top
Gun tar
um they're all ones that we pretty much
expected to hear of but women talking
I'd not heard anything about that what's
that film about yeah women talking it's
coming out um in the UK fairly soon so
that's why you wouldn't have heard so
much about it here yet but it's about a
group of women who are as well and
they're basically like having a
discussion about whether to leave the
highly religious and somewhat abusive
community that they're in uh but it's
it's an incredible screenplay and it's
incredible ensemble cast because like I
said there's very little action it's
mostly they're just in one room most of
the set is just this one barn and
they're having this long discussion so
it's a really interesting that you've
got clear foyer in that haven't you yes
you have and Another Irish star Jesse
Buckley so um yeah it's one to watch out
for when it does hit Cinemas in a couple
of weeks I think a lot of people will be
really pleased to see it in the best
picture category because there were as
it might get snubbed it's interesting
how many big Blockbusters have made the
list as well because at the moment it's
such a strange time for Cinema a lot of
the films that are the more interesting
intellectual offerings if you like
they've done so badly at the box office
and it's interesting that actually
filtering through into the best picture
nomination list certainly it's the ones
they've done really well at the box
office things like Top Gun which I think
before it came out a few people would
have ever thought imagined that Tom
Cruise returning in Top Gun would have
made it into the best picture listed the
Academy Awards that's nominated and it
was offered in quite a lot of the
technical categories as well wasn't it
it's got quite a few nods yeah I've made
it six nods I'm gonna make an Italian as
we go so uh apologies they're not quite
right but yeah certainly a good handful
of nods and Avatar as well I think
they've got four that's just past two
billion at the box office this week so
it shows that you can be a big box
office film and an Oscar film now
there's no reason to be one or the other
but also that you can be a hugely
popular film and get nominated now but
not necessarily go down well with the
critics because not many of the critics
really were raving about Avatar but I
think the the fact that so many people
have gone out and seen it that it's
already made billions and is in the sort
of top five movies that are highest
grossing it shows that look it isn't a
least elitist thing anymore the Academy
Awards they're trying to think about
what people like and really and truly if
they want people to tune in they have to
include the films that people are
watching
um Empire of light another relatively
small budget British film that's that's
in there in cinematography but that's
the only nomination for it which is with
Olivia Coleman yeah that's right none of
the acting nominations that they would
have been crossing their fingers for but
um a great nod for Roger deakins who has
won twice before I believe and been
nominated 15 times a day a friend of the
show yeah yeah
and find out how he's feeling yeah big
fans of his they're really great to see
him nominated today and Katie you
trailed at the famous you said you
thought that Hollywood might uh give
that a bit of a nod this is Steven
Spielberg's story about how he fell in
love with the film and sort of a bit of
a biography that's up there for best
Motion Pictures and got quite a lot of
the other it's done so much better than
it did at the baftas yeah only got one
nomination which just felt a little bit
cruel that it hadn't really received
much more attention than that but here
yeah you've got the um Best Director
Stephen Spielberg I think that's going
to be an interesting field isn't it yeah
sadness coming up for this yeah yeah got
in there although don't forget that film
did win the Palm Door it can so it's got
form for being What triangle of sadness
[Laughter]
there's a lot of vomiting and quite
unpleasant things to watch it's really a
satire about the rich isn't it yeah and
and the privileged but um it's very
funny but yes it's uh not for those
weekends as is here as well and so I you
know they were saying like you've now
got to all rush out and watch all of
these films um not a lot of them haven't
been released here in the UK anyway but
of those best Motion Picture films which
are the ones that you would say we
should all you know which one should we
try and see before then our banshees of
inner sharing is my favorite but they're
closer on the second for me is the Fable
ones just for a gorgeous kind of
all-round heartwarming tale if you like
Steven Spielberg yeah I would agree and
also try and fit an after sun if you can
because that Paul mascal performance is
so special and it's a small British film
so it's a really lovely moment for that
brilliant about you know it's a small
film it's got them up there as best
actor nomination great thank you very
very much ladies really great to take go
through it all with you and uh look
forward to seeing what you're going to
wear on the big day you and the rest of
them thanks a lot and a date for your
Diaries the Oscars will be shown
exclusively live on Sky Showcase from
Midnight on Sunday the 12th of March and
here on Sky News we'll bring you
exclusive coverage of the Hollywood Red
Carpet Of course on the day and we will
have all the winners here on Sky News
that's going to be from 5 00 a.m on
Monday the 13th of March